looming interest rate hikes russia's war
on ukraine and spiking inflation have
wrecked havoc on the markets this year
still these investment fintechs have
picked up millions of customers and
billions of dollars in assets noticeably
absent from this year's list is
robinhood the trading app became
ineligible after going public with a
meteoric 30 billion dollar valuation
shares have since plummeted more than 80
percent as user counts and trading
volume plunged from last year's record
highs
here are the four most innovative
investment companies that made the 2022
fintech 50 list
guideline administers 401k plans for
small businesses for a forty nine dollar
monthly base fee plus eight dollars per
participating employee
the 1.15 billion dollar company based in
austin texas administers more than 30
000 small business 401ks which is up 50
over last year new state laws like one
in california that required businesses
with five or more employees to offer a
retirement savings plan by june 30th are
helping drive growth i capital is a new
york based company worth about six
billion dollars it connects more than
ten thousand financial advisors and
their clients to private equity private
debt venture capital real estate and
hedge funds with as little as 25 000
invested per fund
this is much lower than traditional
minimums for these funds which can run
from 1 million dollars to 10 million
it's now providing its white label
service to over 140 firms including
blackstone deutsche bank and goldman
sachs public.com is also based in new
york and worth 1.2 billion dollars the
brokerage app offers commission free
investing in stocks etfs and
cryptocurrency fractional trading of
nfts and other collectibles and the
ability for users to share their
portfolios and trades public.com's user
base has exploded to 3 million from less
than 1 million at the end of 2020.
finally stash is an app offering
fractional investing in stocks etfs and
iras
it also features checking accounts and a
debit card that rewards purchases with
fractional shares for a flat monthly fee
of one dollar to nine dollars the new
york based company is worth 1.3 billion
dollars it also rolled out smart
portfolio this january it's a stash
managed portfolio matched to an
investor's risk tolerance with a five
dollar minimum investment and four to
six percent allocated to crypto the new
product already has 500 000 users taking
part